how did you see your mom naked um I was
leaving the house someone was calling
the house while I was my mom thought I
left someone the the house phone was
ringing she so this probably about 5
years ago this is like the same week she
fell down the steps this is a good week
me and my mom yeah but then somebody
called for her so I was like Mom the
phone's for you Mom a landline she still
has a land and I was [__] pissed that
she wasn't answering so I like walked up
the steps like [__] mom like to the
[__] phone and then uh she walked out
of her bathroom totally naked bombs out
totally naked and I was like [__] but I
remember she again uh at this time
probably like 60 58 she's cute though
right I mean she's woman yeah she's
she's she's not like she doesn't look
like me she like a fat your dad out
kicked his coverage she no my dad was
hot my dad was very hot did I show you
my dad when he was younger no not my
dad's hot as [__] yeah yeah he was a
beast uh big dick too I saw his dick a
bunch when I was a kid and I was like I
saw at the uh you saw how much he CED
his pants too showed them the picture
that nah we're just going to leave him
in the dark on laser tag and he's got
just a [__] a jellyfish mess why of
my dad was com in his [__] pants he
didn't really come in his pants show
I'll show you the picture in a second
but what the last the thing that stuck
with me my mom my mom was more upset
about it than I was she walked out not
the there was no comment this point s
she walks out of the bathroom I'm
standing there I was like e that's how I
reacted I wasn't like I was just like oh
[__] mom like e e and she was like get
the [__] out of here like she got real
upset but I remember the one thing that
stuck with me is peripheral her jaw was
wired
shot still trying to suck in an Oreo she
she trimmed her pubes oh that means
they're active and this is what I was
saying she's maintaining I remember
being like I thought it was going to be
a [__] chaotic just a bush it was
nice but it wasn't it's the shape of a
heart yeah that's because your dad
requests it I know but I remember being
like that was troubling keep that like
that was the worst part yeah did she do
basically what a [__] dude should be
doing at the very least yeah under the
balls in between I got to be honest it
was or I'm saying did she trim it to the
point where she's shaving and you could
actually see lip I want to know if you
can see lip because I was locked onto
our
tits but
uh think I actually
was I think I was like oh [__] [__] but
uh
I don't know if I feel comfortable D but
it was did you see lip I didn't see any
lip I didn't see any
lip yo went back to the TGI Fridays
though though the TGI Fridays the Mall
of America TGI Friday held it down held
it down put this time I had to defend my
honor I played Dracula 12 actually play
I had to I was like I have to do it I
have to redeem myself drula stole drula
Valor I said it to you on the phone once
and I just broke my heart that I fibbed
it I didn't play Dracula the first time
someone else did so I played it I'd say
four straight times you played it four
straight times I got yeah I played it
maybe five straight were you going up
and doing it or were you hitting from no
I was in the distance I was sniping
you're sniping from your and then
finally a guy one of like the fourth no
one noticed I was like no one notices so
then finally what was the scene how many
people were there a lot oh it was packed
tji Fridays is where all the the
industry all the service industry goes
to hang out afterwards really so all the
fine ass [__] are in there damn all
the waitresses all
the people of color waitresses were in
there really fine ass people of color
damn yes and they were they
werey yeah of course all those [__]
people color but the first couple waves
of Dracula no one noticed the waves but
I overdid it on the touch I played it
too many times in a row so finally this
guy was sitting with girlfriend he was
like from us to the Stoners and I saw
him perk his head up when Dracula came
on again and I was like yo you like
Dracula and he was like is that you
playing this like and I was like no who
was this dude just a random guy on a
date he was like I and then he was like
I had a long day of work I don't like it
that much damn he heard it like six
times [__] on his some white [__]
was like who's playing Dragula trying to
control everything trying to control
everyone's vibing a Dragula everybody
was viral videos probably dudes on like
dancing to Dracula just hot young women
of color dancing a dig through the
ditches and burn I was just I was it was
a [__] VI it was so VI the vibe was
so good and then uh some white [__]
assho some white [__] devil was like
who's playing that and I was like do you
like it and he was like is that you and
I was like no he was like it's
definitely you and then uh I made I
didn't realize I had played it like
three more times it was loaded up how
many more so after I like fought
somebody I was like I'm sorry it just
kept that intro is so funny to hear that
like
weird I foret I don't even know what
noise that is and then uh how's the
intro go uh I don't even know how to
describe it the beginning of Dracula is
like I five no no before the guitar it's
like a weird
like singing song what it is hold on
let's let's actually just let's get the
uh yeah you need to paint a picture here
think of this Muslims women of
color tji
Fridays now think of a dude going like
that he's like God damn it I just want
to enjoy my
burger so then here's what I was doing
yeah it just get spooky as hell out so
spooky and then what you got to do when
you a lot of guys think they're good
with the Touch Tunes Dragon what you got
to do is you got to get the people going
so you got to toss in like a remix to
ignition for sure or like a I'm real
remix a lot of remixes yeah definitely
but once you put on a song that
everybody loves yeah they're all like
they all start dancing and having funj
and then you hit a Dracula you bring him
back in with a [__] Dracula I'm a
counter puncher on the touch you're
DJing this party I yeah djed the tji
Fridays and then people started you
might be DJI
Fridays
DJ High Fridays DJ High Fridays dude
that's pretty sick
name so yeah I was DJing it and we went
out with two me and my lady went out
with two fans after the show two lucky
fellas and then they got to witness me
and my lady getting a
fight like oh you done talking we're not
talking for the rest of the night this
after Dracula this is I mean during
Dracula there was no there was no after
I left with about four Draculas in the
chamber
so yeah if you listen to this and you
the manager has to reset it with the key
if there's too many dragulas lined up
the manager has to come out of the back
like undo a the waitress was upset our
waitress was upset why cuz she was like
is that you doing
that so sorry how I forget this what in
the
hotel in Indianapolis check in I'm like
ah I'm going to jack off yeah I'm in
there there naked on top of the made bed
fully naked I was about to get in the
shower yeah cracked open the lotion I'm
laying there phone like
this dude a dude just opens the
door dude just walks in what and did he
P his eyes and took him a long time to
avert his eyes his gaze was on my body
and I I I also didn't he froze I didn't
move I just was like dude what are you
doing I didn't there was no shame I was
just like what the [__] are you
doing he was like oh I'm sorry sir I'm
sorry I said my life my
rules it was crazy he was like no one's
supposed to be in here I was like well
I'm in here and I'm [__] jacking
off I haven't been caught whacking in so
long I didn't give a [__] I thought I
would be I thought I'd be mortified it
was a lady how was it not a lady a lady
I think might have been worse you think
so that would have been a little
shameful I mean I don't know why I think
dude I just saw an Indian guy's
face and he didn't maybe because the
light maybe because it was dark in my
room and it took him a second to get
adjusted cuz he was like no way dude he
was just feasting his feasted his I mean
it must have looked nuts I was on top of
a white all white bed I was camou I was
like an
octopi he might not have seen you dude I
don't think he saw me cuz he stood there
for a minute
like hello I was like you
dude it's like beauty of the Beast the
furniture are talking away really so
close he opened the front door he
definitely saw you faing on the he saw
me rock hard too as hard as it gets
dude maybe that's why I was not ashamed
if he would have got me early yeah
lotioning up S working a PUD with
lotion [__] you get the [__] out of here
dude God that's the best thing I I
laughed he heard me laughing he he was
like don't tell anyone I was like I'm
not going to tell anyone what the [__]
what's why going get [__] fired oh
yeah if I went down to the desk and I
was like what the [__] was that he
walked in on me masturbating I was in
there masturbating I was Rock [__]
hard I was about to come I had a boner
by the way right back to work of course
dude put the hard hat back on of
course God damn wow and then he knocked
he waited he went outside closed the
door waited like 20 seconds and then
knocked and I was like dude you know
what I'm doing you know you know I'm ass
naked jerking off and he was like I have
your amenities I was like [__] leave
him at the [__] door yeah dude what
are you thinking you still so you had to
I had to stand up rock hard with a
lotion to boner at the hotel talking
through a door like no man you never
have to do that yeah it
was yeah that's crazy it's a wild day
yeah I'm I'm trying to find this picture
so we me and my family went uh to laser
tag we took my niece to play laser tag
and my dad's under the black light we
got inside and my dad's [__] je it's
unbelievable rled okay okay so I get it
now so it wasn't wet with C right then
it was under a black light so we're
standing
in his now going [__] baffled we're
in a semicircle asking that this kid is
giving us the directions to how to play
laser tag and my I hear my sister she's
like Jesus Christ dad and we both me my
sister and my dad all look at the same
time my dad goes Jesus Christ but I have
never laughed that hard of my like full
[__] show him I will I will but list
but then he didn't give a [__] he kept
asking questions like he was drawing
attention to himself he like what if I
uh wait how do I shoot the satellite
what happens if I shoot the satellite he
that 10,000 I'm like Dad shut the [__]
up dude can I change
teams also I had enough time to take my
phone out and take a picture of my dad's
[__] jeans look at his hand in his pocket
tucked in
[__] dude that is a [__] crime yeah
my dad's tough I grew up in a nice house
house and just played video games all
the time my dad grew up like just a
[__] he wanted to grow fish in their
pool over the
winter you put You' catch fish from the
Greek and put him in the pool it would
freeze over and in the summer when it
would fall out beat tons of
dead he was a
[__] oh my God his stories are [__]
hilarious but this was a different time
like he he had to fight other kids at
the Nights of Columbus picnic who REM
being like fourth grade having to fist
fight for the
dads but uh no he got in a fight one
time my uncle my uncle uh Frank he's the
oldest and he's the only one that's not
huge in jacked he's like a normal guy
but I mean he's still a [__] psycho
like he went to Notre Dame he left Notre
Dame he he went to the Marines in
Vietnam and then left and came back and
became a prison
Warden he's a
[__] this is how funny it is cuz he
works he he's been in prisons his whole
life so like he talks like a black guy
from the
70s I I'll see like what's up holes like
all right you J ass [__] like
all right like my my cousin Jeff caught
him bench pressing in the garage
listening to Ghetto boys he's like like
68 [__]
hilarious so he he at the time he was a
volunteer firefighter in Steelton
Steelton Pennsylvania and uh he would he
would he would be like a first responder
so he had a what is it called a scanner
and he would take calls and he would get
to the fire first so he got a call once
and uh he raced over there to get it
these people said there was a house fire
and he got there and it was just a uh
it's just four [__] idiots and it was
a motorcycle that had caught fire that
they just put out with a garden
H my Uncle Joe gets there and it's just
a [__] shitty motorcycle that was on
fire they put it out with a garden hose
and he was like all right well now I
need to use your phone you [__]
idiots they're like all right you can
come use your phone he's inside and he's
still he's talking [__] on the guys that
called he was he called the fire
department he was like hey don't rush
through the city to get here like don't
speed through the [__] City this is
just a [__] fire these [__]
morons set this is something and while
he's talking [__] on these guys calling
him [__] morons one of them just
sucker punches them and knocks them out
in their kitchen just knock my uncle and
they they they obviously went on his way
he went home and he was like well he's
all [__] up he got home and he saw my
dad and I guess he told my dad what had
happened so my dad was like [__] that
[__] we're getting the boys we're going
to these [__] house you know [__]
them up so my dad and three of his
friends one of them had a broken arm
which is
funny a cast on his arm they they get in
the car and they drive over to this
guy's house and they kick the door open
and it's just a family they got the
wrong house
it's just a family watching
TV like the kids were on the floor it
looked nice like where the [__] is he
they like oh they they live next door
like oh
[__] all right thank you and and then
they kick in those guys door and he said
they were just sitting on the couch so
they just him and his four friends just
started beating the [__] out of these
four guys just while they're in their
living room and then uh like the guy
with the cast was hitting them with the
[__] gas and then one of the guys
pulled out a gun so like so then my dad
and his friends ran like just ran he
said they ran right through the [__]
screen door which is
funny but uh while they were running out
one of my dad's friends was like we're
going to burn your [__] house down
you [__] and uh the neighbors whose
house they broke into called the fire
department and my Uncle Joe got the
call Frank Uncle Frank got the call
then I'm run long baby [__] it um a
couple couple years later my dad is
going to buy a six-pack in a bar in
Steelton and he notices those four guys
that they the house they broke into are
playing pool and he was like I could I
remember seeing them through the [__]
uh the mirror behind the bar and he was
like I noticed they noticed me but he
was using his brother Joe's fake
ID and the brother Joe's like he's the
biggest strongest but he's the only nice
one he went to the Naval Academy for
football like he's a big guy but he's
he's kind of a weird [__]
he's in ancestry
now but he was jacked monster and uh he
was a sweet guy so my Dad gives the
bartender his ID he gets the [__] out of
there apparently those guys weren't for
the bartender were like who the [__] was
that and the BART was like that was Joe
Gillis he gave him my uncle's ID so then
a couple couple weeks later my dad's
with his brother Joe and his brother
Joe's back from college and he's like oh
I got I got a notice from the post
office hopefully it's my college
yearbook then he gets to the post office
it was a summons for breaking and
entering an
assault got charged for the Sal and then
you know dropped cuz they were like who
the [__]
that anyway that's it you guys are great
[__] six wood two record see you
[Music]
guys
my mom got knocked out and I didn't
resuscitator Jesus my sister looked at
me my mom fell down the steps she was
shitfaced she's going to love that I'm
telling this story this is great but
yeah my my family was out getting [__]
up and then when they came home I was in
the basement and my mom mom came down to
see me and she had a handful of cookies
and she dropped she had Oreos stop and
she dropped an Oreo and tried to recover
that but she Dove she Dove down the
steps head first [__] Pete Rose slid
and just
[__] trying to save an Oreo and she
got totally knocked out and my sister's
behind her how old are you I'm sorry I'm
30 no at the time sorry at the time this
is probably 2 years ag9 oh no this is
actually probably like four or five
years this is yeah this recent yeah dude
I would throw up laughing if I saw well
I heard my sister I didn't see her fall
my sister was behind her and was like
Mom's dead she was like oh [__] mom mom
she was like Shane come here mom's dead
I was like I came over and my dad was
shitfaced and he was up in the kitchen
and he was like he's he lost his
composure right away he was like what's
going on down there oh he's crying it
was crazy right away trying not to laugh
they were all drunk and my sister was
like call call 911 dad mom's dead oh my
God I get to my mom and she's knocked
out how did you not tell me the story
this is how you should open up every
morning she had black in her mouth from
the Oreos her mouth was all [__]
gross and like purple from the wine oh
my and my sister my sister was like we
got her lips are purple her teeth are
black she kiding but no she was like we
got to give her mouth to mouth she's
like give her mouth to mouth e and even
in a moment where I was convinced she
was dead I was like my mom is dead right
now I was still like you
[__] like in that moment my sister
was like you got to give her mouth to
mouth and I looked at her I was like
[__] I don't you you you give her
mouth to MTH so did she wake up she woke
up the the ambulance did show up so now
we've got a [__] EMT in our [__]
basement and my mom woke up and was
mortified she was like so embarrassed
but she broke her [__] Katie my
sister I stayed the [__] away she'll be
all right she'll be Oreo lick at the
fingers oh she got the Oreos uh
my mom's hand was like oh finger was
totally [__] up and she didn't notice
it because obviously she was knocked out
and then she sits up and it's like I
think my hand hurts like oh
[__] John always Pinky she would cry if
she knew I was telling this story but
yeah no I like I like history so it's
coming I'm not a republican now but it's
it's coming there's no when I'm on the
road I travel every [__] weekend
there's you know there's nothing to do
during the day and then at night you do
stand up but during the day I travel
every week and it's sometimes I like
visit like historical places throughout
the country so a couple summers ago
don't laugh at
that shut up dude it's not lame at
all [__] I just laughed at me from the
balcony
dork so a couple summers ago I was in
Washington DC and I went and I visited
uh Mount Vernon I went and I visited
George Washington's house uh turns out
it was George Washington's
Plantation
ah
Shucks dude I get in there I'm the only
one there it was the first summer during
Co I'm the only visitor there it's me
and if if you've been there before you
know it's 15 reenactors that don't break
character they stayed everyone else was
in the 1700s I was the only guy there
like I signed up for the tour and my
tour guide was Martha
Washington it wasn't her it was some fat
[__] I saw right to
it
I sign up for the tour so me and Martha
have to hang out together for 15 minutes
to see if anybody else signs up for like
the 3:00 tour orever of course they
don't I got to make small talk with a
woman that won't stop pretending to be
from the 1700s it's [__] insane what
do you say I was just out there with her
like where's George
Washington she was like oh the general
he won't be joining us today he's in his
Chambers it's just you and I I was like
wait
you trying to [__]
me never broke no one broke I enough
Times Gone by I've had enough to think
about why nobody would break character
while I was there and for real I'm
fairly certain they thought that I was a
special needs
man like they all got together and they
were like look this is obviously a big
day for this guy nobody break character
let's make it magic for him like they
watched me park my car when I got there
when I got out they were like oh
one of the driving ones look at
him it was also during Co and The Mask
did not do me any favors if you can only
see my eyes I got the eyes for it it was
sunny out
I it also it also didn't help I walked
up to my tour guide like where's George
Washington like oh you're a big guy I
was like yeah
so me and
Martha me and Martha go in for the tour
due to coid restrictions at the time we
were not allowed to speak
indoors all right so for
$36 me and a woman dressed like Martha
Washington [__] dead silently walk
through for a full hour you need to be
able to talk for this tour to have any
value at all there's nothing to read in
there it's just old chairs and [__] me
and this lady went room to room for an
hour and this was the
tour I was in the corner of every room
just not getting
it we get outside when we were done
she's like do you have any questions I
was like yeah what the [__] was that
what was that what' you and me just
do so that was the end of me and Martha
I go off by myself I start looking
around like I said it was the first
summer during Co all right so we're in
the middle you know we're in the middle
of tearing down statue
season and I was at a founding father's
Plantation during all of that so I
wanted to check out the slave
quarters want to see what all the fu was
with huh no whatever [__] you guys what'
you guys do what' you guys do that
summer [__] post black squares on
your
Instagram is that what you
did how dare you judge
me how dare you I was there boots on the
ground at a founding father's
Plantation growing learning as a why
coming for real though I was in there
was in George Washington slave corters
by the way the first thing you do when
you walk into George Washington slave
cours is you go
ooh somehow worse than I thought they
were going to be it's rough dude that
guy had a [__]
dungeon for real you didn't know and I'm
in there and I'm by myself and I'm like
you know you remember that time it was a
tense [__] time in this country and
I'm in there by myself like Jesus
[__] Christ and then I hear some
footsteps coming down the path behind me
and now blocking the only exit of the
room was a slave
reenactor they have those there and he
did not break character I turned around
he was like oh well hello there sir like
Jesus Christ dude please you don't have
to do the
character I'd give anything for you to
not do that
character he didn't break he was good he
was like look at those clothes you must
be from the future hello Tom
traveler I was like no I'm from right
now what are you doing out come
here no I did not say that obviously I
didn't [__] say that I didn't say a
word I was
frozen I was paralyzed I with white
guilt I didn't say a word I
was and he knew what he was doing he for
real he knew what he was doing dude he
wasn't he wasn't giving me the George
Washington tour he was just drilling me
with [__] I didn't want to hear he was
hitting me with the you remember that
time tense time that guy walks in there
and sees me I know what I look like I
know exactly I got you know I've got the
body type of a guy who says let's see
the rest of the body cam footage before
we jump to any
conclusion I know what I look
like he wasn't even giving me the George
Washington tour he was just telling me
[__] up [__] he was talking about
other people he's like Thomas Jefferson
had about six slave children of his own
he only freed two of his own children
during his lifetime I was like Jesus
Christ isn't that a bummer Thomas
Jefferson literally enslaved some of his
own
children yeah now you know how I felt
dude I was getting [__] drilled with
this information that's when I started
playing posum a little bit was like
maybe I am a special needs
guyy
so he was hit me with the [__] white
guil facts I
was it was a battle dude it was like two
wizards
fighting finally I won by just lowering
my mask he was mid- rant
I oh [__] my bad brother you
[__] he let me
go he freed me
that's when I went to the George
Washington museum there's a museum there
that as soon as you walk into that
museum they start pumping up George you
walk in they're like George Washington
was a great man you're
like I just came from his
dungeon but you know I'm American I'll
forget about that part of his history
what else did he do you know we're not
going to let human trafficking Define
these guys are
we
huh
I don't know
anyway I was in there I was going
through the museum I'll admit I still
had I had girl brain towards George from
what I'd seen I was still mad at him was
going through the museum I was like
George Wasing them [__]
[__] like George Washington had red
hair I was like ugly
[__] I was trying to be cool and
liberal and hate him I couldn't do it
dude they started pumping up George got
me going dude
I going through the museum they're like
George Washington was 6'2 I was like
nice like he could never tell a lie I
was like this guy's
unbelievable like he single-handedly
defeated the British at this point I'm
back on not dude I'm worse nobody better
touch my statues I love statues I'm
ready to get on Facebook defend written
house whatever I need to
do to help this country get better
better I'm back 100% love America Love
George Washington and then you get to
the end of the tour and the last thing
you see on the George Washington tour is
George Washington's teeth in a case if
you you know the myth is George
Washington had wooden teeth turns out
George Washington had it was Ivory and
Lead Dentures with horse and cow teeth
on the top row and human slave teeth on
the bottom
row Dam what the [__] that's it that's
how the tour ends you got to walk
outside to a hot sunny parking lot like
what the [__] was that at
the also lead with the teeth show me the
teeth right away dude Don't Make Me Love
George Washington for two hours and at
the very end be like you want to see
some wild [__]
like and once you see his teeth every
story about him makes perfect sense like
he was a man of few words it's like yeah
dude he had [__] donkey teeth and
[__] leaded in his mouth for a decade
you can't keep lead in your mouth for a
decade that would give you for real like
rabies like symptoms you
got like I can't believe we defeated the
British so I know how we did it we had a
[__] 6'2 red-headed [__]
guy out in the woods just waiting for
those [__] dude 62 in 1770
that's like 610 today red hair horse
teeth a sword
just do you want to tax me
[__] you know how terrifying
that guy was coming out of the
woods some five foot British guy
oh it's run it's
George you ever see that painting of
George Crossing the Delaware standing
he's the only one standing on the
rowboat everyone else was like GE you
got to get down they're over there get
them you know what happened that day
when George crossed the Delaware it was
Christmas Day and uh it was a bit of a
massacre because George caught the
British off guard because uh the British
absolutely correctly assumed they were
like uh only a [__] gu's going to
tread across this icy River today in a
rowboat unfortunately for them our first
president was on the other side of that
River so I get in the boat we got to
kill these [__]
for I know I said [__] there a
couple times my bad on
that I'm not trying to give myself a
pass on being able to use that word but
I will say I don't know if you can tell
by looking at me I do have family
members with Down
Syndrome it almost got me
out I dodged it but it nicked me it
nicked
me bit of a day Walker
myself it's funny when you bring up down
syndrome you can always tell who's never
been around it in their lives you know
what I mean like if I tell people if I'm
like yeah I have family members with
Down Syndrome people that have never
been around it are always oh like down
syndrome is the [__] end of the world
oh are they okay your are they doing
okay it's like they're doing better than
everybody I know they're the only dudes
I know having a good time pretty
consistently sorry they're not on
[__] Aderall and anti-anxiety like
the rest of us they're on [__] Capri
Sons
having a good time dude my uncle Danny
my uncle Danny sneaks grilled cheese
sandwiches into restaurants just in case
they don't serve grilled cheese
sandwiches you don't know where he's
getting these [__] things it's the
best it's the best you'll be out to
dinner with him you look across the
table you see him sneaking at grilled
cheese yo where'd you get that chees
Danny his dad's with him he's like that
[__] he's been making him at night I
know he
is I'm not making him at night
Dad and he'll look at you and be like
I'm making them at
night what's better than that dude
what's
better